l'histoire de la ligue du lol alors la
ligue du lol c'est une espèce de
mouvement informel de journalistes dont
on a découvert l'existence la semaine
dernière qui sont aujourd'hui à des
postes parfois de responsabilité dans
des journaux plutôt de gauche
télérama libération les inrocks même
clairement de gauche et qui il ya
quelques années harcelé anonymement sur
twitter des femmes en particulier
alors je voudrais vous faire écouter
cette petite explication qui sait le
d'eric zemmour alors je lui ai posé la
question mais pourquoi à votre avis
est-ce qu'il ya eu ce phénomène de la
ligue du nord et lui dit ben c'est parce
que comme on peut plus parler nulle part
et ben forcément il ya un moment où ou
la soupape éclate mais il va vous dire
mieux que moi chez ces jeunes gens ils
font exactement comme les comme les
soviétiques dans leur cuisine
le net c'est leur cuisine à laon il se
défoule il retrouve les réflexes de
sales gosses de sale gamin avec une
solidarité viril un peu ridicule un peu
stupide un peu grossière mais nécessaire
c'est un rite d'initiation
il faut l'encadrer il faut la civilisé
ça viendra foppa spécial l'éradiquer
tout le problème de cette religion
séculière qui est le féminisme anti
racisme etc
c'est qu'il ne veut pas canalisé il ne
veut pas civilisé il veut éradiquer
il veut changer l'homme et donc ça ne
marche pas par ailleurs ils sont
coupables d'être des procureurs
en fait c'est la logique révolutionnaire
la révolution mange toujours ses enfants
les procureurs finissent par être des
victimes de la cherté qu'est ce que vous
pensez de cette idée selon laquelle
c'est parce que la pression du
politiquement correct est trop forte que
du coup il ya des abus enfin simplement
enfin je pense que c'est pas du tout du
tout le problème
en l'espèce mon avis roues et que c'est
pour ça que ça arrive dans des journaux
de gauche c'est tout ça qui est
sous-entendu non je pense que c'est
vraiment pas la question à mon sens ça
illustre beaucoup surtout la grande
désillusion d'internet c'est à dire
qu'avec les réseaux sociaux on a cru
tenir là un espace d'échangé fabuleux de
délibération démocratique et puis
finalement on s'est aperçu que c'était
pas du tout ça que c'était des bordées
d'injures des agressions incessantes des
excommunications immédiate et qu'en fait
bah voilà
le débat c'était beaucoup plus serein
lieu de sanglants de règlement de
comptes ce qu'ils font là ce qu'ont fait
ces journalistes c'est ce que font les
mômes aujourd'hui sur les réseaux
lorsqu'ils prennent un bouc émissaire
souvent les filles d'ailleurs et qui les
harcèlent c'est vraiment de ce degré là
mais derrière ça il ya aussi l'idée et
c'est là où je reviens à internet que en
fait ces raisons ça permet aussi de se
défausser aisément sur le collectif
alors c'est un mécanisme humain très
vraiment ancestrale mais internet permet
de le faire à très grande échelle et
c'est quand même un problème parce que
précisément c'est un média qui plus
peut-être qu aucun autre demande la
responsabilité des usagers
donc là on est vraiment face à ce
problème avec des gens en plus qui se
présentait et qui sont d'ailleurs des
experts d'internet donc c'est quand même
un énorme paradoxe quoi donc ils ont usé
jusqu au bout de la logique des réseaux
et voilà ce que ça donne
moi je pense que c'est la ligue des
lâches c'est à dire que ça pose le
problème de la face sombre d'internet
dernière c'est un formidable outil une
nouvelle révolution extraordinaire mais
là c'est vraiment la face sombre
c'est à dire des gens qui utilisent leur
pouvoir pour pour mener des pratiques
qu'on pourrait comparer à celle du
bizutage dans l'est dans certaines
grandes écoles voilà ou dans des
établissements scolaires on va on
utilise internet parce que c'est devenu
un immense terrain de chasse des
couverts par l'anonymat pour les
harceleurs peu et pour pour des gens qui
veulent qu'ils veulent exercer des
pressions sur sur certaines personnes
les les jeunes journalistes jeunes
femmes journalistes en sont les
premières victimes et c'est pas du tout
un hasard et donc non je pense que là là
les grandes les grandes les grands
délires philosophique de
de eric zemmour gerder absolument pas je
pense qu'il ne faut avoir aucune
complaisance à l'égard d'une ce type
d'attitude et pas chercher des raisons
autres que une quelque chose qui est
totalement condamnable dîner lé réseau
citer 1 sophie chazot qui a écrit chez
nous un tacle là dessus c'est le mur de
conte d'une certaine presse de gauche
c'est ça le truc c'est l'hypocrisie des
gens qui ont fait la fête d'un mythe ou
et qu'on voit que 20 des années des
années des années ils font contraire
c'est de donner des donneurs de leçons
c'est qu'on m'a c'est comme que c'est
comme à quelqu'un qui est homophobe qu
on découvre un jour ajout qui leur nom
ce soit des tartuffes non mais c est
franchement la presse n'a pas besoin de
ça déjà on a mauvaise presse
on n'avait pas besoin de ça c'est
exactement ce que les gilets gens
pensent de nous d'ailleurs de tous nous
tous
ils font pas la distinction entre
télérama et causeur et tout ça pour us
et tousser dans les kiosques c'est à
brûler donc bon face à frau make sure
sur twitter on vous pose la question à
la sphère de la ligue du lol et l de la
seule responsabilité des journalistes et
vous êtes 61% à nous répondre que oui
babineau nous dit chacun responsable ses
agissements sur internet il n'ya aucune
circonstance atténuante
antoine nous dit le problème est que ces
journalistes font partie des journaux
qui se permettent de donner des leçons
de morale à qui mieux mieux
babineau twitter est un exutoire ça crée
un sentiment de meute
beaucoup le font mais eux pour le coup
sont médiatisés alexandre ii vecchio
outre votre point de vue est ce que vous
êtes sensible à cet argument de séjour
selon lequel c'est peut-être parce que
là comme on l'a toujours adrien dire que
que quand on dit des choses et pas ça
dérape tout de suite moi je pense qu'il
ya le gros problème dans cette affaire
c'est effectivement les postures morales
les gens qui sont pris la main dans le
sac cc guillotine a guillotiné c'était
quand même la vision du monde qu'il
défendrait c'était une vision ricaneuse
dans le pur style canal+ contre tous
ceux finalement qui ne qui ne pensaient
pas comme eux et qui n'était pas cool il
ya une espèce de dictature de cool donc
voilà tous ces gens qui étaient
soi-disant sympas sont finalement pas si
sympa que ça a presque y a
mort d'homme je ne sais pas où il n'y a
pas de trace écrite masse qui me pose
problème c'est que là la guillotine on
sait quand ça commence on sait pas où ça
s'arrête je vois qu'il ya d'autre à
faire que maintenant on espionne les
conversations privées
donc là où je rejoindrai eric zemmour
c'est qu'on a l'impression qu'on va vers
une dictature de la transparence qui est
quand même assez assez inquiétante
et si c'est pour remplacer la dictature
du cool par l'ama trop d'essence euse
c'est pas voilà c'est pas forcément un
progrès il me semble qu'il ya aussi dans
le phénomène mis tout et c'était un
problème dès le départ avec ses
dénonciations anonymes et c'est une
forme d'extrémisme aussi qui est
inquiétant donc finalement ce que dit
zemmour c'est un peu un centriste il dit
que que l'homme est faillible il ya un
merci des chaudières justifiable c'est
le mot c'est puni par la loi
pas du tout je pense qu'ils sont
indignés qu'effectivement ça nous fait
pas du bien à tous parce qu'il ya il ya
un amalgame qui est fait et on remarque
d'ailleurs que bizarrement ça touche
plutôt toujours ce type d'affaires une
presse donneuse de leçons mais je dis
que quand même il faudra faire attention
à l'avenir à faire la différence entre
ce qui relève d'une conversation privée
d'une blague de potache et ce qui est
réellement du harcèlement comme il faut
faire la différence entre un viol et une
blague
mal placé donc voilà je mets en garde
face à la salle à des conversations
privées en fait l'avion ça touche pas en
groupe
voilà alors je vous laisse ça n'était
pas le cas merci beaucoup à tous les
quatre absolument merci savez que je
suis sûr qu'on reparlera de ces sujets
voilà il parle d'une autre affaire si
l'opinion des manuels des manuels d'eric
zemmour vous intéresse elle sera
développée dans le figaro magazine du
week-end prochain merci beaucoup à tous
les quatre bonsoir
[Musique]